how's it going everybody we have
possibly some huge news in regards to
the developments of dr. strange too but
first don't forget about the giveaway
that I'm doing I am giving away a few
copies of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray all you have to do to enter is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video leave a comment below with your
favorite superhero so there has been a
lot of talk about Doctor Strange - Kevin
Feige president of Marvel Studios came
out and said that there definitely will
be a Doctor Strange - but what hasn't
been talked about is the timeframe of
when we'll get it
Marvel has been pretty reluctant to
announce movies that take place after
Avengers 4 for obvious reasons they want
us to think that everybody that died
with the snap and Avengers infinity war
is dead for good but we're not buying it
despite the Russo brothers attempt to
troll us and convince us that nobody's
coming back we know they are Doctor
Strange was a huge success there's no
way they're not making a number 2 plus
Doctor Strange had a huge role in
infinity war and will most likely have a
big role in Avengers 4 as well and today
it seems like we got a little bit more
evidence that Doctor Strange 2 will be
happening scott derrickson who was the
director for the first Doctor Strange
movie posted a little something on
Instagram he posted this photo with the
caption not my will but thine be done
see you in September it's hard to think
that this could be about something
besides Doctor Strange - Scott directed
the first movie Marvel likes to keep
their directors for their sequels
especially if they did really well which
Doctor Strange did and he posted a
picture of Doctor Strange so what else
could it be about besides Doctor Strange
- now I don't think they're going to
start filming in September especially
since they're not really done reshooting
some parts of Avengers 4 but I do think
that this is where the cast and the crew
will come together writers producers
everybody and talk about the direction
that they want to take Doctor Strange -
they left more dough there to be the
villain and the next Doctor Strange but
one of the writers teased earlier this
year
he'd like to bring a nightmare to be the
villain maybe they can have them both or
maybe they're just gonna push more to
back even further or who knows but it
does seem like Doctor Strange 2 is going
to be talked about and the production is
gonna start this year which is great
news because we really had no idea when
we were going to get the sequel and
Doctor Strange is the man can't wait for
it what do you all think about this post
from scott derrickson director of the
first Doctor Strange movie do you think
that it means that we're going to get
Doctor Strange 2 sooner than later or do
you think this simply means nothing or
do you have a theory of um let me know
in the comments below again don't forget
about the giveaway all you have to do is
subscribe to this channel leave a like
and drop a comment below with your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]